on va voir ce qui est excité ce qui me
dégoûte pas faire une interview stimulus
la dentelle par exemple la dentelle
cette existence est dégoûte
ouais la dentelle
une marine le pen en revanche toujours
de donges les dentelles western ouais
ouais c'était si le sac dégoûte
ça m'excite la dentelle c'est bien que
ça s'excite et sa très courte mais ça me
dégoûte en même temps cette équipe mais
sa mixité vrai dire une mêlée enfin une
fille intelligente va dans une fille
intelligente suis dit la dégoûte cet
excitant cette prise est répugnant
les talons aiguille chatte etc si tous
sont des gouttes les tanneries green
on s'adresse complètement indifférente
n'a pas lécher les talons aiguilles par
exemple pour laquelle une voiture bien
les missions qu'on sera dans la boîte
les poignées d'amour c'est sexy tous ept
dégoûte
de même les touches et oui moi la
télévision de cette ex itou 7 dégoûte
ça m'excite pas pas de seins pas d'y
être
non mais là c'est toi qui nous excite à
la moyenne des gouttes les odeurs
corporelles sa t'excite ou 7 des gouttes
ça m'excite excessivement ah oui oui et
même à lattes les odeurs de l'intérieur
du corps à les voir gagner
ça me fait penser au livre des maynats
vrai c'est l'aimant les cas tous âges
cet excitant cette dégoûte
nicolas je vais pas dire bonjour j'ai
remarqué tout de suite en arrivant il
n'a pas tenu des colorier un brouillon
et j'appelle palerme et je suis dit mais
gagner colle à sa texture est celui ci
non les des fans tout nu avec un bon sac
est chaud entendre tes voisins faire
l'amour c'est t'excite ou 7 des gouttes
ça dépend si c'est en dessous si ses
voisins du sud soudan dessus ouais c'est
du suisse en musique c'est un grand pays
qu'est le lui a bien sûr un transsexuel
cette existence est dégoûté répond jean
l'orissa t'excite ou 7 des gouttes aller
même si claire we can oui même
énormément mes enfants
vie en fermant les yeux j'aime
énormément c'est juste un super week-end
à
après tintin c'était si tout ça te
dégoûte portez des sous-vêtements
féminins c'est excitant cette dégoûte
et bien je le confesse oui en fait c'est
un hobby cas quoique irish mois sur toi
moi je suis jamais de sous-vêtements jeu
c'est bien laurent je n'en porte pas si
tu devrais le savoir plus le temps je
zappais lio qui vient dîner 7 excite
tout ça dégoûte
ça plombe un peu la soirée jeux basés
sur ce sera une soirée pleine de vie de
deux d'entousiasme de parti pris dedans
volet nous ce sera forcément une bonne
soirée
vous allez par bertrand cantat sûrement
ce premier sujet abordé les poils
partout 7 excite tous ept déchets rio
toujours non
voilà des poils partout c'est teksid se
dégoûte avec cette présélection à sucer
un orteil 7
c'est peut-être mon point faible à
vincent delerm 7 excite tous ept dégoûte
non je l'aimais beaucoup au fait qu'ils
veulent te rends compte maintenant
j'aime énormément je vais à chaque fois
je lui ai dit je laime davantage tu vois
ça comme ça viendra cette émission à
cette technique ou 7 des gouttes
bah je vais je j'avais une fête une fête
d'anniversaire
j'étais coupé un peu en plein vol entre
deux coupes de champagne savalas la
soirée suit son cours d'une façon plutôt
cohérente